This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This week, Donald Trump returns to the White House, and he's promised, on day one, to begin carrying out the largest domestic deportation operation in American history. Trump plans to mobilize federal and local law enforcement to remove millions of undocumented immigrants from the country. But already he's facing pushback from cities and states across the country that have declared themselves sanctuaries and say they won't cooperate. This is a fight we've had many times before and back in 2017 during Trump's first term we aired a two-part series exploring the origins of the sanctuary movement. We thought this would be a good week to revisit that story. Here it is. In July 1980, a group of Salvadoran migrants crossed the border from Mexico into Arizona.
这里是《九十九%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。本周，唐纳德·特朗普重返白宫，他承诺在上任第一天就开始执行美国历史上规模最大的国内驱逐行动。特朗普计划动员联邦和地方执法力量，将数百万无证移民驱逐出境。但在此之前，他已经遭到全国各地城市和州的阻挠，这些地方宣布自己是庇护城市，并表示不会予以配合。我们以前多次经历过这样的斗争，早在2017年特朗普第一任期内，我们就播出了一个两集系列节目，探讨庇护运动的起源。我们觉得本周重温这个故事正合适。以下是节目内容。1980年7月，一群萨尔瓦多移民跨越墨西哥和亚利桑那州之间的边境。
They walked over an isolated mountain range and halfway across a wide desert valley. There were more than two dozen of them, people who'd left behind lives and jobs to come to the United States. They'd hired some guides to lead them on the journey. Reporting our story this week is Delaney Hall. And those guides had brought them to a largely uninhabited part of the border. It was a vast, empty, and fatally hot stretch
他们步行穿过一座孤立的山脉，走了一半宽阔的沙漠山谷。当时有二十多个人，他们为了来到美国而抛弃了生活和工作。他们雇了一些向导带领他们进行这次旅程。本周我们的报道记者是德兰妮·霍尔。而那些向导把他们带到了边境一个基本上无人居住的地区。这是一片广阔、空旷且酷热致命的
of the Sonoran Desert. The temperature the next day got up to around 112, 115 degrees out there. It was deadly. This is John Fife. He's a Presbyterian minister from Tucson, which is a couple of hours from where the migrants crossed. They were in the middle of the most desolate and deadly area of the desert. And I think out of the group of 26, 12 of them died the first day out.
索诺拉沙漠。第二天那里的气温高达112到115华氏度左右。这是致命的。这是约翰·费夫。他是来自图森的一位长老会牧师，图森距离移民越境的地方有几个小时的车程。他们身处沙漠中最荒凉、最致命的区域。我想26个人当中，有12个人在出发的第一天就死了。
The survivors were eventually found delirious and suffering from intense dehydration and heat stroke. Some of them had stripped off their clothes. Border Patrol agents brought them to a hospital in Tucson, which is where Reverend John Fife met them. And they asked some of us who were pastors to provide some pastoral care for the survivors who were traumatized beyond understanding.
幸存者最终被发现时神志不清，并遭受着严重的脱水和中暑。他们中的一些人甚至脱掉了衣服。边境巡逻队特工把他们送到图森的一家医院，也就是在那里，约翰·费夫牧师见到了他们。他们要求我们这些牧师为那些受到超乎想象创伤的幸存者提供一些牧灵关怀。
And they began to tell me why they'd fled El Salvador. At that point, Reverend Fife had lived in Tucson for more than 10 years, leading a small congregation at a church called Southside Presbyterian. He didn't know much about Central America, or what was going on in countries like Nicaragua, Guatemala, and El Salvador around this time. Not only ignorant, but I couldn't have put El Salvador on a map.
他们开始向我讲述他们逃离萨尔瓦多的原因。当时，费夫牧师在图森生活了10多年，在南区长老会教堂领导着一个小型会众。他对中美洲或当时尼加拉瓜、危地马拉和萨尔瓦多等国发生的事情并不太了解。不仅一无所知，而且我当时连萨尔瓦多在哪里都指不出来。
I knew it was somewhere between Mexico and Panama, but that was the extent of my knowledge. So I had a lot to learn and a lot of catching up to do. The people of El Salvador are caught in a web of terror trapped between the military forces of the Irina government and the guerrilla forces of the FMLN. No one is safe in this civil war. El Salvador's civil war had been decades in the making. Since the early 1900s, the country had been ruled by a series of oligarchs and corrupt military leaders.
我知道它大概在墨西哥和巴拿马之间，但我的了解也就仅限于此了。所以我有很多东西要学，也有很多落后的功课要补。萨尔瓦多人民陷入了一张恐怖的网络，被伊里纳政府的军事力量和法拉本多·马蒂民族解放阵线（FMLN）的游击队夹在中间。在这场内战中没有人是安全的。萨尔瓦多的内战经历了数十年的酝酿。自20世纪初以来，该国一直由一连串寡头和腐败的军事领导人统治。
They maintained control by repressing large segments of the rural population. In the late 1970s and early 1980s, a number of left-wing guerrilla groups began to grow in power and influence. The military responded by trying to crush this resistance. Death squads targeted union leaders, community organizers, and other people they suspected of sympathizing with the guerrillas. That included priests and nuns. Lots of civilians were caught in the middle of this violence.
他们通过压制广大农村人口来维持控制。在20世纪70年代末和80年代初，许多左翼游击队开始壮大并扩大影响力。军方则试图通过镇压这种抵抗来进行回应。行刑队将工会领袖、社区组织者以及他们怀疑同情游击队其他人作为目标。这其中也包括神父和修女。大量平民被卷入这场暴力的漩涡之中。
Thousands of people were disappeared, murdered, or displaced. Today the Salvadoran people continue to suffer as a persistent pattern of brutal human rights violations grips the nation. And El Salvador wasn't the only country where this was happening. Similar conflicts were unfolding in Nicaragua and Guatemala, where authoritarian governments were facing pressure from left-wing rebels. This is the history Reverend John Fife started to learn about when he met the Salvadoran migrants who'd nearly died in the desert near Tucson. Well, basically, they were telling me why they'd fled El Salvador, about threats from
成千上万的人失踪、被谋杀或流离失所。今天，由于持续不断的残酷侵犯人权行为笼罩着这个国家，萨尔瓦多人民仍在继续遭受苦难。而且萨尔瓦多并不是唯一发生这种事情的国家。类似的冲突也在尼加拉瓜和危地马拉展开，那里的威权政府正面临来自左翼叛军的压力。这就是约翰·费夫牧师在图森附近的沙漠中差点死去的萨尔瓦多移民时开始了解到的历史。嗯，基本上，他们是在告诉我他们为什么要逃离萨尔瓦多，关于
death squads, killings of members of their family or close friends, that sort of thing, and the reason why they'd had to flee. He didn't know it then, but Reverend Fife was witnessing the beginning of something big. Hundreds of thousands of Central Americans were trying to get away from these dangerous and bloody civil wars. They were fleeing their countries, making their way through Mexico, and crossing into the United States. So a major migration of refugees occurred along this border during that 10-year period beginning in 1980. Reverend Fife's church sat less than 100 miles from the border, and it would be completely swept up in this crisis. Eventually, Fife and his congregants would give shelter to hundreds of Central Americans.
行刑队的威胁、他们的家人或密友被谋杀之类的事情，以及他们不得不逃亡的原因。当时他并不知道，费夫牧师正在见证一件大事的开端。成千上万的中美洲人正试图逃离这些危险而血腥的内战。他们逃离自己的国家，穿过墨西哥，并越境进入美国。因此，在从1980年开始的这十年期间，沿着这条边境发生了大规模的难民移民潮。费夫牧师的教堂距离边境不到100英里，它也将被完全卷入这场危机之中。最终，费夫和他的会众将为数百名中美洲人提供庇护。
They'd be joined by a network of churches across the country, all opening their doors and giving migrants a safe place to stay. This would mark the beginning of a new and controversial social movement based on the old religious concept of sanctuary, the idea that churches have a duty to shelter people fleeing persecution. More than 6,000 people have signed up to provide sanctuary around the country. The sign today cracks down on so-called sanctuary cities. The modern sanctuary movement in the U.S. can trace its roots back to Reverend Fife.
他们将得到全国各地教堂网络的加入，所有这些教堂都敞开大门，为移民提供一个安全的地方居住。这将标志着一项基于古老宗教庇护概念的新且充满争议的社会运动的开始，即教堂有义务庇护逃离迫害的人。全国各地已有6000多人报名提供庇护。今天的标志打击了所谓的庇护城市。美国现代庇护运动的根源可以追溯到费夫牧师。
Today we're going to look at how it began and why it caused one of the biggest showdowns between church and state in recent memory. After that first encounter with the Salvadorans at the hospital, Reverend Fife began to see more and more Central Americans arriving in Tucson. Some of them would come to his church and ask for help. And at first, his inclination was to work within the rules of the immigration system. I was pretty naive at that point. And I went to the immigration office here in Tucson,
今天我们将探讨它是如何开始的，以及为什么它引发了近年记忆中教会与国家之间最大规模的对决之一。在医院与萨尔瓦多人进行了第一次接触之后，费夫牧师开始看到越来越多的中美洲人抵达图森。他们中的一些人会来到他的教堂寻求帮助。起初，他的倾向是在移民系统的规则之内运作。我当时相当天真。我去了图森这里的移民局办公室，
met with the director, and said, we're seeing refugees who are fleeing for their lives. What do we need to do to protect them? And he said, well, we have good political asylum law in the books. And if they're deserving of political asylum, if they're refugees, they'll get political asylum. Asylum, you apply for if you are within the United States and have a well-founded fear of persecution. I'm talking law here.
与局长会面，并说道：“我们看到正在为生命而逃亡的难民。我们需要做些什么来保护他们？”他说：“嗯，我们在法案中有很好的政治庇护法。如果他们值得获得政治庇护，如果他们是难民，他们就会得到政治庇护。”庇护，如果你身在美国境内并且对遭受迫害有合理的恐惧，你就可以申请。我这里说的是法律。
This is Ruth Ann Myers. I was district director of the Immigration and Naturalization Service for Arizona in 1984 and a couple years later they added Nevada. Since 1980 when Congress passed the Refugee Act the US has asked people to meet a number of requirements in order to be granted political asylum. They have to establish that they fear persecution in their home country based on their race, religion, nationality, political opinion, or social group. They also have to convince immigration that their government is actually involved in their
这是露丝·安·迈尔斯。我曾在1984年担任亚利桑那州移民归化局的地区主管，几年后他们又将内华达州划归我管辖。自1980年国会通过《难民法》以来，美国一直要求人们满足多项要求才能获得政治庇护。他们必须证明他们因为种族、宗教、国籍、政治见解或社会团体而害怕在祖国受到迫害。他们还必须说服移民部门，他们的政府确实参与了他们的
persecution or that it can't control the groups that are. If someone shows up in the U.S. and they can meet those requirements, they're supposed to be able to stay. But it's not always that simple. Meyers used to interview people seeking asylum, and she says it could be tough to establish a person's status. It relied heavily on a single individual's testimony
迫害，或者政府无法控制实施迫害的团体。如果有人来到美国并且能够满足这些要求，他们理应能够留下来。但事情并不总是那么简单。迈尔斯过去常常面试寻求庇护的人，她说要确定一个人的身份可能很困难。这很大程度上依赖于单个个人的证词，
about what they'd been through. It depends on the individual. It depends on what they say and how they say it. And if they have any backing. So basically it was my decision based on my experience and what the person said, because as you can understand, there was very little physical evidence of this. Despite the challenges of qualifying for asylum,
讲述他们经历过的事情。这取决于个人。这取决于他们说什么以及他们怎么说。并且看他们是否有任何支持。所以基本上这是基于我的经验、我的理解以及这个人所说的话做出的决定，因为正如你所能理解的，这方面的实物证据非常少。尽管获得庇护资格面临种种挑战，
Reverend Fife and his church raised some money and organized legal assistance for the migrants. They started visiting detention centers and helping people fill out asylum applications. They arranged for lawyers to represent them in court. But it began to seem like even the people who met the requirements for asylum were not getting it. Like even in cases where there was physical evidence. I can remember taking in a guy who had been tortured in El Salvador. And we flew in an Amnesty International doctor who testified that, yeah, this guy's been tortured. I'm an expert on the physical effects of torture. And the immigration judge would order him deported the next day.
费夫牧师和他的教堂还是筹集了一些资金，并为移民组织了法律援助。他们开始访问拘留中心并帮助人们填写庇护申请。他们安排律师在法庭上代表他们。但渐渐地，似乎连那些符合庇护要求的人也没有得到庇护。比如甚至在有实物证据的情况下也是如此。我记得曾接待过一个在萨尔瓦多遭受过酷刑的人。我们用飞机接来了一位国际特赦组织的医生，他作证说：“是的，这个人受过酷刑。我是酷刑生理影响方面的专家。”而移民法官第二天就会下令将他驱逐出境。
Reverend Fife began to wonder what was behind these decisions to deport. Central Americans hoping for asylum faced some significant hurdles. For one thing, just as they began turning up along the U.S.-Mexico border in 1980, tens of thousands of refugees from other places like Cuba and Iran were also seeking refuge in the United States. The government was overwhelmed with applications. Most Central Americans had also historically come to the U.S. for jobs, not because of political persecution.
费夫牧师开始琢磨这些驱逐决定的背后到底是什么原因。希望获得庇护的中美洲人面临着一些重大的障碍。一方面，就在他们于1980年前后开始出现在美墨边境时，来自古巴和伊朗等其他地方的数万名难民也正在美国寻求避难。政府的申请应接不暇。而且历史上大多数中美洲人来美国是为了工作，而不是因为政治迫害。
The government was more inclined to see them as economic migrants. And on top of that, there was the Cold War. — Mr. Speaker, distinguished members of the Congress, honored guests, and my fellow Americans. — In 1983, President Ronald Reagan delivered a special televised speech before Congress. In it, he outlined his concerns about the civil wars flaring up in Central America. Central America's problems do directly affect the security and the well-being of our own people. Reagan saw Central America as an important front in the Cold War, a region so close to the U.S. that our national security required us to stop communist movements from flourishing there. Nicaragua is just as close to Miami, San Antonio, San Diego, and Tucson as those cities are to Washington Washington where we're gathered tonight.
政府更倾向于将他们视为经济移民。最重要的是，当时正处于冷战时期。——议长先生，各位尊贵的国会议员，受人尊敬的嘉宾，以及我的美国同胞们。——1983年，罗纳德·里根总统在国会发表了一场特别的电视讲话。在讲话中，他阐述了自己对中美洲燃起的内战的担忧。中美洲的问题确实直接影响到我们自己人民的安全和福祉。里根将中美洲视为冷战中的一个重要前线，这个地区距离美国如此之近，以至于我们的国家安全要求我们阻止共产主义运动在那里蓬勃发展。尼加拉瓜距离迈阿密、圣安东尼奥、圣迭戈和图森的距离，就和这些城市距离我们今晚聚集的华盛顿的距离一样近。
Just a few years earlier, in 1979, a socialist revolution actually did happen in Nicaragua. The Sandinista National Liberation Front had ousted a U.S.-backed dictatorship, which had ruled the country for decades. At the time of this speech, the Reagan administration was sending aid to Contras fighting the new socialist Sandinista government. And the U.S. was also doing its best to suppress similar left-wing movements in El Salvador and Guatemala,
就在几年前的1979年，尼加拉瓜确实发生了一场社会主义革命。桑地诺民族解放阵线推翻了一个受美国支持、统治该国数十年的独裁政权。在那次演讲时，里根政府正在向与新的社会主义桑地诺政府作战的反政府武装（Contras）提供援助。美国也在尽最大努力镇压萨尔瓦多和危地马拉类似地左翼运动，
which meant backing the authoritarian governments that still had a grip on power in those countries. In summation, I say to you that tonight there can be no question the national security of all the Americas is at stake in Central America. Thank you. God bless you. So here's how this all connects back to Tucson and the deportations that Reverend Fife was
这意味着要支持那些在这些国家仍然牢牢把持着权力的威权政府。总之，我要对你们说，今晚毫无疑问，整个美洲的国家安全都系于中美洲。谢谢你们。上帝保佑你们。所以，这一切是如何与图森以及费夫牧师所看到的驱逐行动联系起来的呢？
seeing. Because the U.S. government considered the governments of El Salvador and Guatemala to be political allies in the fight against communism, it denied these governments were persecuting their own people. Under Reagan, almost all Salvadoran and Guatemalan border crossers were classified not as political refugees but as economic migrants. That meant they didn't qualify for asylum. They got sent back.
由于美国政府认为萨尔瓦多和危地马拉政府是打击共产主义的政治盟友，它否认这些政府在迫害自己的人民。在里根的领导下，几乎所有越过边境的萨尔瓦多人和危地马拉人都被归类为经济移民，而不是政治难民。这意味着他们没有资格获得庇护。他们被遣送回国了。
Ruth Ann Myers, the former INS director in Arizona, says immigration officers followed policy set by the government, which has broad discretion when it comes to asylum decisions. The immigration officers, whether it be enforcement or the asylum officers or whatever, were not making up their criteria or the law. This all came from Congress.
露丝·安·迈尔斯，亚利桑那州移民归化局（INS）前局长，表示移民官遵循的是政府制定的政策，在涉及庇护决定时政府拥有广泛的自由裁量权。移民官员，无论是执法人员还是庇护官员或其他人员，都没有凭空捏造他们的标准或法律。这一切都来自国会。
The result of this policy was stark when it came to Salvadorans in Guatemalans. Between 1983 and 1986, fewer than 3% of Salvadorans in Guatemalans who applied for asylum were approved. In that same period, the approval rate for Iranians was 60%. For Afghans fleeing the Soviet invasion, it was close to 40%. In that same period, the approval rate for Iranians was 60%. For Afghans fleeing the Soviet invasion, it was close to 40%. Back in Tucson, that put Reverend Fife and his congregants in a tough position. They didn't want to encourage migrants to report to immigration when they knew it was almost certain they'd be deported.
当涉及萨尔瓦多人和危地马拉人时，这项政策的结果是严酷的。在1983年至1986年间，申请庇护的萨尔瓦多人和危地马拉人中只有不到3%获得批准。在同一时期，伊朗人的批准率为60%。对于逃离苏联入侵的阿富汗人来说，这一比例接近40%。在同一时期，伊朗人的批准率为60%。对于逃离苏联入侵的阿富汗人来说，这一比例接近40%。回到图森，这使得费夫牧师和他的会众陷入了艰难的境地。他们不想鼓励移民去向移民局报到，因为他们知道这些人几乎肯定会被驱逐出境。
So they held a series of meetings to figure out what to do. And that's when Jim Corbett started showing up. It's hard to describe Jim because he was a unique figure. Jim Corbett died in 2001. But back in the 80s, he lived on the edge of Tucson. He raised goats, and he knew a lot about philosophy. He was also a Quaker. And as the refugee crisis in Tucson continued to grow, Jim's religious faith compelled him
于是他们举行了一系列会议来商讨对策。就在那时，吉姆·科比特开始出现了。很难描述吉姆，因为他是一个独特的人物。吉姆·科比特于2001年去世。但在20世纪80年代，他住在图森的边缘。他养山羊，并且对哲学知之甚多。他也是一名贵格会教徒。随着图森难民危机的不断加剧，吉姆的宗教信仰驱使他
to take action. He'd started letting refugees stay at his house and in some of the ramshackle trailers scattered around his property. So Jim starts coming to meetings at Southside Presbyterian Church where they're discussing the deportations. And after one of those meetings, Jim comes up to Reverend Five. And his contention at that point to me was, John, I don't think we have any choice under the circumstances except to begin to smuggle people safely across the border so that they're not captured and detained
采取行动。他开始让难民住在他的家里以及散落在他房产周围的一些简陋拖车里。于是吉姆开始参加南区长老会教堂的会议，他们在会上讨论驱逐出境的问题。在其中一次会议之后，吉姆走到费夫牧师面前。他当时向我提出的观点是：“约翰，在这种情况下，我看我们别无选择，只能开始把人们安全地走私过境，这样他们就不会被抓获、拘留
and deported. My response was, how the hell do you figure that, Jim? And he explained. Jim explained that they needed to consider two moments in history. The first was back in the 1800s, when church people, a lot of them Quakers, helped move runaway slaves across state lines and through the Underground Railroad to safety. And he basically said, we have to conclude from history that they got it right. Those were the folks who understood and got it right. Then Jim pointed to the church and its failure to protect Jewish people fleeing the Holocaust in the 1930s and 40s. Many Jews were detained and deported back to Germany, where they were
和驱逐出境了。”我的反应是：“吉姆，你到底是怎么想的？”然后他作了解释。吉姆解释说，他们需要考虑历史上的两个时刻。第一个是在1800年代，当时教会的人（其中许多是贵格会教徒）通过地下铁路帮助逃亡的奴隶跨越州界到达安全地带。他基本上是说，我们必须从历史中得出结论，他们做对了。那些人理解并做对了。然后吉姆指出了教会及其在1930和1940年代未能保护逃离大屠杀的犹太人的失败。许多犹太人被拘留并被驱逐回德国，在那里他们被
killed. Jim argued that Christians should have done more to protect them. And he said, they failed. They failed completely. As people of faith, as the church. And I said, yeah, you're right. And his punchline was, John, I don't think we can allow that to happen on our border in our time. And after a couple of sleepless nights, I went back to him and said, yeah, you're right. I cannot be a pastor of a church here on the border and not do what you're asking. So sign me up." At this point, Jim Corbett had already done some border runs on his own, picking up migrants
杀害。吉姆认为基督徒本该做更多事情来保护他们。他说：“他们失败了。他们彻底失败了。作为信仰群体，作为教会。”我说：“是的，你是对的。”他的点睛之笔是：“约翰，我认为我们不能让这种事在我们这个时代、在我们的边境发生。”在经历了几个不眠之夜后，我回到他身边说：“是的，你是对的。我不能当一个边境这里的教堂牧师却不做你要求的事。所以算我一个。”此时，吉姆·科比特已经自己进行过一些边境偷运，在墨西哥接上移民并帮助他们越境进入美国。但现在费夫牧师和其他少数几个人开始协助他。起初他们把人带过来并安置在吉姆家里，但很快他们就清楚地发现需要更多空间。于是，吉姆再次来找费夫牧师谈话。他希望教堂开始接待难民。这是一个需要全体会众共同面对的问题。对于人们来说，这不是一个容易做出的选择。他们交谈、祈祷，然后投票决定让中美洲难民留在教堂里。很快，在任何一个
in Mexico and helping them cross the border into the United States. But now Reverend Fife and a handful of others started helping him. At first they'd bring people across and put them up at Jim's house, but it quickly became clear they needed more space. So once again, Jim came to talk with Rev. Fife. He wanted the church to start hosting people. That was a question that the whole congregation had to deal with. And that's not an easy choice for people to make. They talked and prayed and then voted to let Central American refugees stay at the church. Soon, on any given stay at the church.
夜晚，教堂里都会有几十个人睡在主聚会空间里。教会成员将提供食物、衣服、英语课程、医疗服务以及获取法律咨询的途径。他们将帮助难民策划下一步该怎么做。这并不是说移民是绝对安全的。他们仍然没有合法身份，并面临被驱逐出境的可能，但他们可以获得资源、指导和一个地方
Soon, on any given night, the church would have dozens of people sleeping in the main gathering space. Church members would provide food, clothes, English lessons, medical care, and access to legal advice. They'd help the refugees strategize about what to do next. It wasn't as if the migrants were entirely safe. They were still undocumented and faced possible deportation, but they had access to resources, guidance, and a place
来栖身。南区教堂的会众在决定将难民接到他们的教堂时，汲取了长期的宗教传统。这实际上是关于寺庙、教堂、犹太会堂和土著人民神圣场所的古老传统，其历史可以追溯到我们所知的任何历史。在希腊和罗马历史中，面临迫害威胁的人可以在寺庙中找到庇护。当罗马帝国成为基督教国家时，教堂承担了相同的功能。庇护的概念也可以在《中世纪教会法》和英国普通法中找到。
to stay. The congregation at Southside was drawing on a long religious tradition when they decided to take the refugees into their church. It's actually an ancient tradition of temples and churches and synagogues and sacred sites of indigenous peoples that goes back as far as any history we know about. In Greek and Roman history, people who were threatened with persecution could find protection in temples. When the Roman Empire became Christian, churches took on the same function. The concept of sanctuary can also be found in medieval canon law and British common law.
随着欧洲民族国家的演变，其中一些国家在法律上承认了教堂庇护人的权力。最近，教堂在越南战争期间庇护了反战兵役拒服兵役者。但尽管费夫牧师承袭了悠久的宗教传统，他和他的会众仍然在窝藏非法越境进入该国的无证移民。事实证明，政府一直在密切关注他们不断壮大的行动。好吧，在这种情况下我们该怎么办？我们得出的唯一结论是，唯一的选择就是将我们正在做的事情公开
And as nation states evolved in Europe, some of those nations legally recognized the right of churches to shelter people. More recently, churches sheltered conscientious objectors during the Vietnam War. But even though Reverend Fife was drawing on a long religious tradition, he and his congregants were still harboring undocumented immigrants who crossed into the country illegally. And as it turns out, the government was keeping an eye on their growing operation. Well, what do we do under those circumstances? And the only conclusion we came to was, well, the only choice we have is to go public
出去。他们认为，也许通过公开，教堂能够引起关注和公众支持。他们邀请了其他几家教堂加入他们的公开声明。1982年3月，他们在教堂正前方悬挂了两条巨大的横幅。上面用西班牙语写着：“这是上帝为中美洲受压迫者设立的庇护所，移民部门，请勿亵渎上帝的庇护所。”
with what we're doing. They thought maybe by going public, the church could generate attention and public support. They invited a couple of other churches to join them in a public announcement. And in March of 1982, they hung two huge banners on the front of the church. They said in Spanish, this is a sanctuary of God for the oppressed of Central America, and immigration, do not profane sanctuary of God.
他们举行了一场礼拜仪式，并公开欢迎一个来自萨尔瓦多的新家庭加入其他留在教堂的难民行列。他们举办了一场新闻发布会，确切地解释了庇护运动是什么以及他们的目标是什么。所以，是的，我们登上了一些全国新闻。在美国西南部，庇护运动已经成了一个高度情绪化的问题。该运动的支持者，主要是教会人士，帮助来自中部的难民……所谓庇护运动的所有成员，他们为非法
They held a service and publicly welcomed a new family from El Salvador to join the other refugees who were staying at the church. And they staged a press conference to explain exactly what the Sanctuary Movement was and what their goals were. So yeah, we made some national news. In the American Southwest, the Sanctuary Movement has become a highly emotional issue. Supporters of that movement, mainly church people, helped refugees from central to central... All members of the so-called Sanctuary Movement that offers aid, comfort, and shelter to illegal
外国人提供援助、安慰和庇护……美国各地大约有200家教堂加入了庇护运动，发誓如有必要将违反法律。随着该运动曝光度增加，它变得更具争议性。但联邦政府认为良心不是违反法律的好借口。我们对任何此类运动的反对意见在于它凌驾于法律之上。尽管政府有这些反对意见，该运动仍在继续发展。越来越多的教堂和犹太会堂开始与费夫牧师取得联系。他们会打电话给我们说：“你们能送给我们一个家庭吗？
aliens... About 200 churches across the United States have joined the Sanctuary Movement, vowing to violate the laws if necessary. As the movement gained visibility, it became more controversial. But the federal government contends conscience is not a good excuse for violating the law. Our objection to any such movement is that it takes law into its own hands. Despite these government objections, the movement continued to grow. More and more churches and synagogues started to get in touch with Reverend Fife. They'd call us and say, can you send us a family?
我们要宣布庇护。”一个网络开始发展起来，这意味着费夫牧师和吉姆·科比特必须弄清楚如何安全地将难民跨国运送到能够支持他们的教堂。因此，吉姆和我基本上拿着一张美国地图坐在这里，然后说：“好吧你在阿尔伯克基认识谁，你在丹佛认识谁，你在全美各地认识谁，这样我们才能转移人员？”我们真的在一个下午就构思出了一条地下铁路，并且我们以旧的地下铁路为蓝本。到20世纪80年代中期，全美数百家教堂和犹太会堂加入了庇护运动。几乎所有主流基督教教派都参与进来了，包括路德宗、卫理公会和浸信会。庇护志愿者来自各种各样的
We're going to declare sanctuary. A network started to develop, which meant Reverend Fife and Jim Corbett had to figure out how to safely transport refugees across the country to the churches that could support them. So Jim and I basically sat down here with a map of the United States and said, okay, who do you know in Albuquerque and who do you know in Denver and who do you know across the United States so we could move people? And we literally in one afternoon figured out an underground railroad and we modeled it on the old underground railroad. By the mid-1980s, hundreds of churches and synagogues across the country had joined the sanctuary movement. Almost every mainstream church denomination had gotten involved, including Lutherans, Methodists, and Baptists. Sanctuary volunteers came from a wide variety
政治观点，包括保守派。但每个人都有一个共同的信念，即教堂需要对中美洲危机做出回应。这些美国教堂与延伸至墨西哥和中美洲的教堂网络相连。因此，移民可以接入这个网络并一路向北。一些人会在墨西哥找到庇护，
of political viewpoints, including conservative. But everyone shared a belief that churches needed to respond to the Central American crisis. These American churches were connected to a network of churches that extended down into Mexico and Central America. So migrants could plug into this network and make their way north. Some would find shelter in Mexico,
另一些人则会继续进入美国。这正是帕特里夏·巴塞洛所做的。我叫帕特里夏·巴塞洛。我是来自危地马拉的难民，自1985年以来一直居住在美国。帕特里夏在危地马拉城长大，她的父母在内战期间是工会组织者，这使他们成为了政府的目标。他们给我的爸爸妈妈贴上参与颠覆活动并想要推翻政府的标签。
others would continue into the US. That's exactly what Patricia Barceló did. My name is Patricia Barceló. I am a refugee from Guatemala, and I have lived in the United States since 1985. Patricia grew up in Guatemala City, and her parents were union organizers during the Civil War, which made them a target of the government. They labeled my dad and my mom as being involved in subversive acts and wanting to overthrow the government.
这足以让他们杀死你、让你失踪，或者对你做出他们想对你做的任何事。有一次，帕特里夏的父亲失踪了几个星期。他被军方或警察绑架了。帕特里夏的家人从未确切得知是谁干的。他回家时已经不复当年风采，瘦骨嶙峋，可以说皮包骨头。他留着长长的胡子。一点也不像我爸爸了。但他回来了。伴随着他的归来，他讲述了一个关于酷刑和对他所做的惨无人道的事情的可怕故事。
And that was enough for them to kill you, disappear you, or do whatever they wanted to do to you. At one point, Patricia's dad disappeared for many weeks. He'd been kidnapped by the military or the police. Patricia's family never learned exactly who. He came home being the shadow of a man that he was because he was so skinny and, I mean, bony. He had a beard so long. He didn't look anything like my dad. But he'd made it back. And with him, he read a horrible story of torture and things that had been done to him that were just inhumane.
那时，帕特里夏的父母逃到了墨西哥城，把帕特里夏和她的妹妹留给了祖母。她的父母说，等他们有了计划就会联系。整整两年，杳无音讯。然后是她母亲的一封信。信上说：“你知道的，把女孩们带到边境，把她们带到恰帕斯的这个公园，我会在那里等着。”
At that point, Patricia's parents fled to Mexico City, leaving Patricia and her sister with their grandmother. Her parents said they'd be in touch when they had a plan. For two years, nothing. And then a letter from her mother. And the letter said, you know, bring the girls to the border, bring them to this park in Chiapas and I will be there waiting.
帕特里夏和她的妹妹从危地马拉越境进入墨西哥，在指定的公园见到了他们的妈妈。他们得知她遇到了一些参与庇护运动的贵格会教徒。贵格会教徒告诉这家人前往墨西哥北部，在那里他们遇到了一位名叫里卡多·埃尔福德（Ricardo Elford）的神父。他与费夫牧师密切合作。他想知道危地马拉发生了什么。他想知道为什么我们要来美国。他说：“你知道的，就告诉我，你知道的，发生了什么，因为我们想带你们来。我们只想知道我们能为你们做些什么。”我妈妈把发生的一切都告诉了他，然后他说，一切
Patricia and her sister crossed the border from Guatemala into Mexico and met their mom at a designated park. They learned that she'd met some Quakers involved in the sanctuary movement. The Quakers told the family to head to northern Mexico where they were met by a Catholic priest named Father Ricardo Elford. He worked closely with Reverend Five. He wanted to know what had happened in Guatemala. He wanted to know why we were wanting to come to the U.S. He said, you know, just tell me, you know, what went on, because we want to bring you. We just want to know what we can do for you. And my mom told him everything that happened, that the two, and then he said, everything
都会好起来的。埃尔福德神父正在对这个家庭进行背景审查。他要确保他们符合难民资格。随着庇护网络的发展，他们不得不制定一个更加正式的流程。这部分是为了确保他们有限的资源用于帮助最需要帮助的人。这也是为了尽量确保
is going to be okay. Father Elford was vetting the family. He was making sure they qualified as refugees. As the sanctuary network had grown, they'd had to develop a more formalized process. This was partly to ensure their limited resources went towards helping people who were most in need. It was also to try and ensure
他们没有将志愿者置于危险之中，也没有将危险人物带入美国。政府对庇护运动的批评之一是他们缺乏评估潜在难民的专业知识和资源。政府担心他们可能会帮助罪犯进入该国，或者帮助想要破坏美国政府的共产主义者。这是费夫牧师的再次发言。
they weren't putting volunteers at risk or bringing someone dangerous into the US. One of the government's criticisms of the sanctuary movement was that they lacked the expertise and resources to evaluate potential refugees. The government worried they might be helping criminals enter the country, or communists who wanted to undermine the US government. Here's Reverend Fife again.
我只会笑笑说：“你们不了解教会。我们拥有世界上最好的情报系统。据我所知，你们说你们现在在萨尔瓦多有五个中情局特工。我有成千上万个。他们被称为神父和牧师。我所要做的就是拿起电话给他们打电话，他们就会把整个家族史告诉我。”一旦埃尔福德神父确信帕特里夏和她的家人确实符合难民身份的要求，他就安排他们被带过边境进入美国。
I would just kind of smile and say, you don't understand the church. We have the best intelligence system in the world. As I understand it, what you say is you have five CIA agents in El Salvador right now. I have thousands. They're called priests and pastors. And all I have to do is pick up the phone and call them, and they'll give me the whole family history. Once Father Elford was satisfied that Patricia and her family actually met the requirements for refugee status, he arranged for them to be brought across the border into the US.
我们在清晨被一辆黄色的卡车接上。我们被扔进车厢后部，直接压在许多睡袋下面。他们告诉我们，无论如何，我们的头都不能露出来。我们只能呆在下面。这家人越境进入亚利桑那州道格拉斯，
We got picked up very early in the morning in this yellow truck. And we were thrown in the back right under lots of sleeping bags. And they told us that no matter what, we couldn't pop our heads up. We just had to stay underneath. The family crossed into Douglas, Arizona
然后前往图森，在那里他们住在圣迈克尔圣公会教堂，这是镇上另一座宣布庇护的教堂。在那儿住了六个月后，他们搬进了一栋房子，并开始了申请留在美国的漫长程序。他们经历了六年多的法律纠葛才获得庇护。每当想起庇护运动为她和她的家人所做的一切，帕特里夏仍然会情绪激动。
and then headed to Tucson, where they stayed at St. Michael's Episcopal, another church in town that had declared sanctuary. After living there for six months, they moved into a house and started the long process of applying to stay in the US. It took them more than six years of legal wrangling to receive asylum. Patricia still gets emotional thinking about what the sanctuary movement did for her and her family.
我记得我父母谈论过这件事，他们说：“你知道的，谁会这么做？谁会拿他们的生命冒险，你知道的，他们在美利坚合众国的优渥生活，为了像我们这样的人？”但随着运动规模越来越大、知名度越来越高，整个行动也变得更加充满风险。老实说，我从没想过我们能逃脱惩罚。我的意思是，我第一次去边境越境时，大约在1981年的某个时候，我必须让自己习惯这样一个事实：我们无法逃脱惩罚，政府会来找我们。这只是时间问题。约翰是对的。这只是时间问题，庇护运动的宗教动机
I remember my parents talking about this and saying, you know, who would do this? Who would risk their lives, you know, their good lives here in the US for people like us? But as the movement grew bigger and more visible, the whole endeavor became riskier. Well, quite frankly, I never thought we were going to get away with this. I mean, the first time I went to the border to do a crossing, 1981, sometime, I had to get comfortable with the fact that we weren't going to get away with this, that the government was going to come after us. And it was only a matter of time. John was right. It was only a matter of time, and the religious motivations of the sanctuary
并没有从政府那里得到多少同情。广告之后继续。欢迎回来，我们播出的这一集最初是在2017年首播的，就在特朗普刚上任后不久。我们现在重温这个故事是因为，嗯，他又回来了，1980年代的历史再次具有了现实意义。这是制片人德兰妮·霍尔的报道。到1980年代中期，庇护运动已经变得引人注目且备受争议。这是NBC大约在那个时候播出的报道。在圣玛丽教堂的会众眼里，他们是英雄。在联邦政府眼里，他们是将外国人走私到这个
movement didn't get much sympathy from the government. That's after the break. We're back with an episode that first aired in 2017, not long after Trump first took office. We're revisiting that story now because, well, he's back and the history from the 1980s is relevant once again. Here's producer Delaney Hall. By the mid-1980s, the sanctuary movement had become very visible and also very controversial. Here's a report that aired on NBC around that time. In the eyes of the congregation at St. Mary's Church, they are heroes. In the eyes of the federal government, they are criminals who smuggle aliens into this
国家的罪犯。政府不喜欢教堂公开蔑视移民法、窝藏无证移民的行为。移民归化局（现称为移民和海关执法局或ICE）辩称，这些人中的许多人并没有合法的庇护申请。该机构的立场是，这些移民中的许多人来美国是为了找工作，而不是因为害怕政治迫害。来自萨尔瓦多的难民。
country illegally. The government didn't like that churches were openly defying immigration law in harboring undocumented immigrants. The Immigration and Naturalization Service, now known as Immigration and Customs Enforcement, or ICE, contended that many of these people didn't have legitimate asylum claims. The agency's stance was that many of these migrants had come to the U.S. to find jobs, not because they feared political persecution. A refugee from El Salvador.
政府坚称他和像他这样的人来这里是出于经济原因。但这个年轻人列出了他逃离祖国的其他原因。杀戮、镇压、苦难和饥饿。美国政府发现自己陷入了困境。他们可以允许教堂继续公开无视法律，或者他们可以对该运动展开调查，并冒着通过针对富有同情心的教堂工作人员而引发公众不满的风险。1984年，政府对庇护运动展开了调查。
The administration contends he and others like him have come here for economic reasons. But the young man listed other reasons for fleeing his homeland. Killing, repression, misery, and hunger. The U.S. government found itself in a tough situation. They could allow the churches to continue openly disregarding the law, or they could launch an investigation into the movement and risk public disapproval by targeting sympathetic church workers. In 1984, the government launched an investigation into the sanctuary movement.
他们将其命名为“索杰纳行动”（Operation Sojourner），这是一个意指旅行者或流浪者的圣经词汇。其目标是收集足够的证据来起诉该运动的领导人，并阻止教堂为难民提供庇护。就在政府展开调查后不久，几个新志愿者接近了庇护运动的成员，询问他们是否可以参与进来。他们的名字叫杰苏斯·克鲁斯和所罗门·格雷姆。我想他们不符合通常的庇护志愿者档案，对吧？对于我们得到的普通志愿者来说，他们看起来有点强硬，在边境上经验太丰富了。
They called it Operation Sojourner, a biblical term for traveler or wanderer. The goal was to collect enough evidence to indict the leaders of the movement and to stop churches from sheltering migrants. Shortly after the government launched its investigation, a couple of new volunteers approached members of the sanctuary movement, asking if they could get involved. Their names were Jesus Cruz and Solomon Graham. I thought they don't fit the usual sanctuary volunteer profile, right? They look a little tough and a little too experienced on the border for the average volunteer we're getting.
这是约翰·费夫牧师。费夫说，尽管克鲁斯和格雷姆看起来有些不同，但他的原则是欢迎所有说想要帮忙的人。他们脖子上挂着十字架，表现得像是听说过庇护运动并想成为其中一部分的人。所以我们欢迎他们并让他们加入进来。——克鲁斯和格雷姆开始参加会议，并协助通过庇护网络运送中美洲移民。
This is Reverend John Fife. And Fife said that even though Cruz and Graham seemed a little different somehow, it was his policy to welcome all who said they wanted to help. They had crucifixes around their necks, and they presented themselves as folks who'd heard about the sanctuary movement and wanted to be a part of it. So we welcomed them and included them in. — Cruz and Graham began attending meetings and helping transport Central American migrants
——他们会开车把人们从图森送到菲尼克斯，或者从菲尼克斯送到阿尔伯克基，或者从菲尼克斯送到洛杉矶。所以他们会驾驶地下铁路的各个路段。但事实证明，克鲁斯和格雷姆并非普通的志愿者。他们是卧底线人。政府雇用他们是为了渗透到运动中并收集证据。克鲁斯和格雷姆都曾是走私犯。
through the sanctuary network. — They would drive folks from Tucson to Phoenix, or from Phoenix to Albuquerque, or from Phoenix to LA. So they would drive legs on the Underground Railroad. But as it would turn out, Cruz and Graham were not ordinary volunteers. They were undercover informants. The government had hired them to infiltrate the movement and gather evidence. Cruz and Graham were both former smugglers.
他们曾在边境担任向导，非法将人们带入该国。然后他们被移民局抓获。他们达成了一项协议：如果他们渗透进我们内部并向政府通报我们的所作所为，政府不仅会付给他们报酬，还会撤销对他们的指控。移民归化局（INS）决定使用他们可能用来对付任何犯罪走私团伙的相同战术来调查庇护运动。该机构并没有被像费夫牧师这样的人的宗教动机所动摇。以下是时任INS局长艾伦·纳尔逊（Alan Nelson）1985年接受ABC采访时的发言。
They'd worked on the border as guides, bringing people into the country illegally. Then they'd been caught by immigration. And they'd reached an agreement that if they would infiltrate us and inform the government about what we were doing, that they would not only pay them, but drop the charges against them. The INS had decided to investigate the sanctuary movement using the same tactics they might use against any criminal smuggling enterprise. The agency wasn't swayed by the religious motivations of people like Reverend Fife. Here's Alan Nelson, the then Commissioner of INS, speaking with ABC in 1985.
——如果你和我为了策划抢劫银行而在教堂建筑里开会，并且以祈祷开始、以祈祷结束，我认为没有多少人会说这是一个应该受到保护的教堂礼拜活动。——他们有权去想他们想的事。任何人都可以。但这并不排除他们必须服从美利坚合众国的意志。——这是露丝·安·迈尔斯。她在1984年成为亚利桑那州的INS地区主管。她没有监督对庇护运动的调查，
— If you and I are meeting in a church building to plan to rob a bank and open with a prayer and close with a prayer, I don't think many people would say this is a church service that should be protected. — They have the right to think what they want. Anybody does. That doesn't exclude them from obeying the wills of the United States. — This is Ruth Ann Myers. She became the INS district director for Arizona in 1984. She didn't oversee the investigation into the sanctuary movement,
但当她到达菲尼克斯办公室时，她被告知了这一情况。是的，我完全感到惊讶。以我的经验，我以前并不知道有教堂会违法并窝藏非法外国人。走私和窝藏。迈尔斯说这个案子非常直接明了。这些人触犯了法律，触犯了美利坚合众国的法律。我赞成合法移民，但不支持非法移民。我认为我们有权拥有我们的法律
but she was briefed on it when she arrived at the Phoenix office. Yeah, I was totally surprised. In my experience, I had no knowledge before of a church breaking the law and harboring illegal aliens. Smuggling and harboring. Meyers says the case was pretty straightforward. These people were breaking the law, the law of the United States. I'm in favor of legal immigration, but not illegal immigration. I think we have the right to have our laws
并执行它们，并决定谁能进入这个国家，谁不能。克鲁斯和格雷姆以及其他几名政府特工进行了长达10个月的卧底，收集针对教堂庇护工作者的证据。他们的手段最终受到了公众的严格审查，因为他们不仅渗透了庇护运动。他们还秘密录制了会议、对话，时间大约是晚上8点。
and to enforce them and decide who comes into this country and who doesn't. Cruz and Graham, along with a couple of other government agents, spent 10 months undercover, gathering evidence against the sanctuary workers. Their methods would eventually come under public scrutiny, because they hadn't just infiltrated the sanctuary movement. They were also secretly recording meetings, conversations, time is about 8 p.m.
并且去执行这些法律，决定谁能进入这个国家，谁不能。克鲁斯和格雷厄姆以及其他几个政府特工，进行了长达10个月的卧底调查，搜集针对庇护所工作人员的证据。他们的手段最终受到了公众的严格审视，因为他们不仅渗透进了庇护运动，还在秘密录制会议、对话，当时时间大约是晚上8点。
For God will deliver the needy when they cry for help. These undercover methods struck some people as offensive and overreaching. Here's Anthony Lewis, then a professor at Harvard Law School, speaking to ABC News in 1985. Oh, it's the methods that bother me. ABC News in 1985. The state was infiltrating and secretly surveilling churches, in a country where the separation of church and state is a deeply held ideal. We reached out to two agents who were involved with the case, and both declined to speak
因为神必拯救哀求的穷乏人。这些卧底手段让一些人感到被冒犯和越权。这是当时担任哈佛法学院教授的安东尼·刘易斯在1985年接受美国广播公司（ABC News）采访时的言论。哦，这些手段才让我困扰。ABC新闻1985年。在一个政教分离被奉为核心理念的国家里，政府却在潜入并秘密监视教堂。我们联系了两位参与此案的特工，但他们都拒绝与我们交谈
to us. The people overseeing the investigation at INS thought these methods were justified. They saw the movement as more political than religious. Yes, there were many that thought it was under the guise of the church. Meaning, the sanctuary workers were using religion as a cover to push a political agenda and undermine immigration laws. And it's true that some sanctuary volunteers were vocally critical of the American policy in Central America. Some expressed support for the left-wing movements developing there. In fact, there was a divide within the movement itself about whether their work should be
移民归化局（INS）中负责监督此案调查的人认为这些手段是正当的。他们认为这场运动具有政治性质，而非宗教性质。是的，有许多人认为它披着教会的外衣。也就是说，庇护工作者利用宗教作为掩护，来推动政治议程并破坏移民法。确实，一些庇护志愿者曾公开批评美国在中美洲的政策。一些人表达了对当地蓬勃发展的左翼运动的支持。事实上，庇护运动内部也存在分歧，即他们的工作究竟应该
motivated primarily by humanitarian concerns or political ones. That debate got to the point where we decided to have a gathering and try to resolve it. But two weeks before that meeting was supposed to happen, the government indicted 16 of the sanctuary workers in Tucson, including Reverend Fife. On January 14th, 1985, federal agents swept down, arresting 63 Guatemalan and Salvadoran refugees across the United States and handing out indictments
主要出于人道主义关切，还是政治关切。这场辩论甚至到了我们决定举行集会并试图解决它的地步。但在那次会议召开前两周，政府在图森起诉了16名庇护工作者，其中包括法伊夫牧师。1985年1月14日，联邦特工雷霆出击，在全美各地逮捕了63名危地马拉和萨尔瓦多难民，并对庇护运动的16名领袖提出了起诉。那天早晨，法伊夫牧师正在睡觉，突然听到有人敲他的前门。于是我起床走到门前，那里站着两名边境巡逻特工。他当时最关心的，是那些住在马路对面、他家正对面的南海长老会教堂里的难民。我脑子里闪过的唯一一个念头是，我教堂里有这么多弱势群体。我得想办法拖住这些人。
to 16 leaders of the sanctuary movement. That morning, Reverend Fife was sleeping when he heard someone banging on his front door. And so I got up and I went to the door and there were two border patrol agents there. His immediate concern was for the refugees that were staying at Southside Presbyterian Church right across the street from his house. The only thought that occurred to me was, I got all these vulnerable people over in the church. I need to keep these guys occupied.
于是我邀请他们进来，煮了咖啡，用各种可能的方式拖延时间。他把官员交给他起诉书从头到尾读了一遍，试图争取一些时间。我的指控非常明确，而且对每个人来说都很典型。有很多项罪名：串谋违反联邦法律、窝藏非法外国人、运送非法外国人，以及协助和教唆非法外国人。每个人在这些类别下都有不同的指控。最终，边境巡逻特工离开了，法伊夫牧师和庇护运动的其他领导人陷入了一个令人生畏的境地。
So I invited them in, made coffee, stalled every way I could. He read through the entire indictment the officers had handed him, trying to buy some time. My charges were pretty clear, and they were pretty typical of everyone. They were a number of counts of conspiracy to violate federal law, harboring illegal aliens, transporting illegal aliens, and aiding and abetting illegal aliens. And everyone had different counts under each of those categories. Eventually, the Border Patrol agents went on their way, and Reverend Fife and the other leaders of
他们面临一场即将到来、备受瞩目的审判，他们将与联邦政府正面对抗。针对他们的指控非常严重。如果罪名成立，他们可能会在监狱里度过多年。他们开始着手组建律师团队来为自己辩护。在我看来，庇护有两个基础。其实很简单。这是詹姆斯·布罗斯纳汉，辩护律师之一。
the Sanctuary movement were left with a daunting situation. They faced an impending high-profile trial in which they'd be facing off with the federal government. And the charges against them were serious. If convicted, they could spend years in prison. They got to work assembling a team of lawyers to defend them. So there's two bases, as I see it, for sanctuary. It's very simple, really. This is James Brosnahan, one of the defense lawyers.
首先是宗教。许多教堂、许多宗教都有一个明确的清规戒律，即你必须帮助那些在路上、正在逃离某种形式的暴力和压迫的人。这是耶稣的教导。辩护方认为，有一个论点可以成立，即庇护工作者只是在按照他们的信仰行事。不仅如此，律师们相信，庇护运动参与者的宗教权利受到了侵犯
The first is religion. And many churches, many religions have as a distinct imperative that you are to assist people who are on the road and who are fleeing some form of violence, oppression. It's the teaching of Jesus. The defense thought there was an argument to be made, that the sanctuary workers were just acting in accordance with their faith. Not only that, the lawyers believed the religious rights of the sanctuary workers had been violated
潜入他们教堂并进行秘密录音的政府特工侵犯了他们的权利。这是对在教堂里研读圣经的人的恐吓。辩护方论点的第二部分与庇护法有关。法律规定，当一个人出现在边境并且他们正在逃离某些特定种类的压迫或暴力时，他们有权进来。当这是真的，并且能够在移民法庭上得到证实，
by the government agents who'd infiltrated their churches and made secret recordings. And that's intimidation of people who are pursuing their Bible studies in a church. The second part of the defense's argument had to do with asylum law. The law provides that when a person shows up at the border and they are fleeing certain specific kinds of oppression or violence, they have a right to come in. And when that is true, and that can be established
这个人就有权留在美国。这就是庇护。随着辩护团队对法律的研究深入，他们开始相信他们的客户其实根本没有违反法律。他们认为美国政府才违反了法律。我既研究了美国政府是如何处理来自中美洲的人的庇护申请的，也研究了国际法律。这是A·贝茨·巴特勒三世，庇护志愿者的另一位律师。
in an immigration court, that person is entitled to stay in the United States. That's asylum. As the defense team researched the laws, they started to believe that their clients hadn't really violated the law at all. They thought the U.S. government had. I did research both how the United States government was handling asylum applications from people from Central America, and I also researched international law. This is A. Bates Butler III, another lawyer for the sanctuary volunteers.
我对我所发现的情况感到震惊，美国政府似乎在系统性地拒绝来自中美洲的庇护申请。这一切都发生在美利坚难民政策发生重大转变的背景下。1980年以前，美国接收难民的方法具有鲜明的政治色彩。它给予逃离共产主义国家和中东国家的难民以优待。1980年，卡特总统签署了《难民法》将其确立为法律。该法本应通过采纳更加人道、非意识形态的难民定义来建立一个更公平的系统。
And I was appalled by what I discovered about how the United States government was systematically, it seemed, denying asylum applications from Central America. This was all happening in the context of a major shift in U.S. refugee policy. Before 1980, the U.S. approach to taking in refugees had been expressly political. It gave preference to refugees fleeing communist countries and countries in the Middle East. In 1980, President Carter signed the Refugee Act into law. The law was supposed to create a fairer system by adopting a more humanitarian, non-ideological
它采用了联合国制定的标准，将难民定义为任何因种族、宗教、国籍、社会群体或政治观点而具有正当理由害怕受到迫害的人。尽管当里根上台时这些新标准已经到位，但庇护工作者的律师们认为政府并没有遵循自己的法律。他们认为移民归化局拒绝了大量本应有资格成为政治难民的萨尔瓦多人和危地马拉人。
definition of a refugee. It used the criteria developed by the United Nations, which identified a refugee as anyone with a well-founded fear of persecution based on race, religion, nationality, social group, or political opinion. Even though these new criteria were in place when Reagan came into office, the lawyers for the sanctuary workers believed the government was not following its own law. They thought INS was turning away large numbers of El Salvadorans and Guatemalans who should have qualified
巴特勒最初得知庇护运动时曾持怀疑态度，但他的研究改变了他的看法。因此，我的立场从“好吧，这很好很棒，这也是出于宗教应该做的事，但它是违法的”，转变为了解救这些人是合法的，而且这正是宗教应该做的事，但它却是违法的。我从那个立场转变为：帮助这些人是合法的，而违反法律的是美国政府。
as political refugees. Butler had been skeptical of the sanctuary movement when he first learned about it, but his research had changed his mind. And so I moved from a position of, well, this is all fine and dandy and this is the religious thing to do, but it's illegal. I moved from that position to it's lawful to help these people and it is the religious thing to do, but it's illegal. I move from that position to it's lawful to help these people and it's the United States government that is violating the law.
-♪ 统治之神……被告及其支持者今天上午游行前往菲尼克斯的联邦大楼，参加首轮传讯。指控包括：非法运送外国人、窝藏外国人和共谋。在法庭内部，被告被指控非法运送外国人、窝藏外国人和共谋。在法庭内部，被告对指控表示不认罪。他们被无保释放。
-♪ God of reign... The defendants and their supporters marched to the federal building in Phoenix for the first round of arraignments this morning. The charges, transporting aliens illegally, harboring them, and conspiracy. Inside the courtroom, the defend transporting aliens illegally, harboring them and conspiracy. Inside the courtroom, the defendants pleaded not guilty. They were released without bail.
他们的审判日期定在4月2日。庇护人士表示，这些审判将是对这个国家宗教自由的一次重大考验。今天下午在图森，进行了更多的传讯。经过数月的筹备，辩护团队信心满满。他们认为自己拥有富有同情心的当事人、大量的公众支持以及令人信服的法律论据。
Their trials were set for April 2nd. The sanctuary people say those trials will be a major test of religious freedoms in this country. This afternoon in Tucson, more arraignments. After months of preparation, the defense team was feeling confident. They thought they had sympathetic clients, a good amount of public support, and compelling legal arguments.
再次请出法伊夫牧师。我们的立场是，哦，我们欢迎有机会在法庭上陈述案情。我们认为我们将稳操胜券。但随后，在极早的阶段，辩护团队遭遇了重大挫折。我们认为我们将稳操胜券。但随后，在极早的阶段，辩护团队遭遇了重大挫折。政府的主诉检察官是一位名叫唐纳德·里诺二世的律师。
Here's Reverend Fife again. Our position was, oh, we welcome the opportunity to make that case in court. And we think we're going to win in a slam dunk. But then, very early on, the defense team faced a major setback. and we think we're gonna win in a slam dunk. But then, very early on, the defense team faced a major setback. The lead prosecutor for the government was a lawyer named Donald Reno Jr.
他的第一步行动之一就是提交了一系列动议，要求审理此案的联邦法官限制辩护方可以提出的论点。接着，审理我们案件的联邦法官裁定，在审判期间，我们不能就五个主题进行任何自我辩护：美国难民法、国际难民法、萨尔瓦多现状、危地马拉现状，或者我们的宗教信仰。这彻底摧毁了我们的整个法律立场。我的意思是，还剩下什么？什么都没了。我的律师解释说，好吧，联邦法官在刑事起诉中拥有巨大的权力，可以排除他们认为与针对被告的指控无关的证据。
And one of his first moves was to file a series of motions, asking the federal judge who was hearing the case to limit the arguments the defense could make. And then the federal judge who was hearing our case ruled that we couldn't say anything in our defense during our trial about five subjects, United States refugee law, international refugee law, conditions in El Salvador, conditions in Guatemala, or our religious faith. So that wiped out our entire legal position. I mean, what was left? Nothing was left. And the way my attorney explained it was, well, federal judges in criminal prosecutions have enormous power to exclude evidence that they believe is not
这位法官实际上将案件简化到了最基本的层面。庇护工作者是否参与了走私和窝藏无证人员的阴谋？是或否。关于背景、历史或动机，没有任何讨论的余地。其中一名被告是一个名叫吉姆·科比特的人。他与法伊夫牧师一起帮助创立了庇护运动。科比特于2001年去世，但在一次档案采访中，他描述了辩护团队所处的困境。
relevant to the charges that are being filed against the defendant. The judge had effectively reduced the case to its most basic level. Had the sanctuary workers engaged in a conspiracy to smuggle and harbor undocumented people? Yes or no. There was to be no discussion about context, history, or motivations. One of the defendants was a man named Jim Corbett. Along with Reverend Fife, he'd helped to found the sanctuary movement. Corbett died in 2001, but in an archival interview, he described the situation that the defense
他说，这就好像一个人深夜在严寒中开车。他的车抛锚了，于是他走到附近的一栋房子。强行闯入，然后被发现并被交付审判。而法官排除了任何能够表明当时气温零下40度、他的车坏了、他停下来并走到该地区唯一的房子里并进入其中的证据。在不了解背景的情况下，吉姆认为陪审团绝不可能理解为什么庇护工作者决定庇护中美洲人。现在，就紧急避险抗辩而言，我们在一个非常不同的语境下谈论着与因逃避酷刑和谋杀而背井离乡的人非常相似的事情。
team found itself in. He said it was as if a man was driving late at night in freezing weather. His car breaks down, so he goes to a nearby house. And breaks in, and then is discovered and brought to trial. And the judge rules out any evidence that would indicate that it was 40 below, his car had gone bad, he had stopped, went to the only house in the area, and entered it. Without understanding the context, Jim thought there was no way the jury could understand why the sanctuary workers had decided to shelter Central Americans. Now, in terms of the necessity defense, we're talking about something very similar with
但是，剥夺提及这种紧急避险的权利简直是对法律的嘲弄。这位名叫厄尔·卡罗尔的法官于2017年2月上旬去世。我们曾请求采访检察官唐纳德·里诺二世，但他目前仍然是现被称为移民和海关执法局（ICE）的活跃诉讼律师。该机构拒绝了我们与他交谈的请求。但他曾出现在1985年的一则新闻报道中，他将庇护运动描述为，引述：
people fleeing torture and murder in a very different context. But to rule out the ability to refer to that necessity simply makes a mockery of the law. The judge, named Earl Carroll, died in early February of 2017. We requested an interview with prosecutor Donald Reno Jr., but he's still an active litigator for what's now known as immigration and customs enforcement. The agency declined our request to speak with him. But he was featured in a news report from 1985, and he described the sanctuary movement as, quote,
一场走私外国人的阴谋。被告诱导、鼓励、走私、运送并窝藏非法外国人。政府表示，这与贩毒没有太大区别。在接下来的几个月里，检方陈述了针对庇护工作者的案情，在很大程度上依赖于其卧底线人的证词。里诺将庇护运动定性为一场纯粹的走私行动。辩护团队试图在交叉盘问中削弱这些陈述，并在可能的情况下偷偷塞入有关背景和动机的细节。
an alien-smuggling conspiracy. The defendants induced, encouraged, smuggled, transported, and harbored illegal aliens. The government says that's not much different from drug smuggling. Over the next several months, the prosecution laid out its case against the sanctuary workers, relying heavily on testimony from their undercover informants. Reno characterized the sanctuary movement as a smuggling operation, pure and simple. The defense team tried to undermine those accounts in cross-examination and to sneak
但在大多数情况下，他们的双手被绑，当轮到辩护方陈述案情时，他们拒绝让任何人出庭作证。在甚至没有盘问单一个证人的情况下，陪审团的审议最早将于下周开始。据称庇护……陪审团进行了超过48小时的审议，跨越了九天。1986年5月1日，在起诉书下达16个月后，审判开始六个多月后，陪审团步入法庭宣读裁决。
in details about context and motivation when they could. But in most ways, their hands were tied, and when it came time for the defense to present their case, they declined to put anyone on the stand. without questioning a single witness, jury deliberations could begin next week. It is alleged that the sanctuary... The jury deliberated for more than 48 hours, spread over nine days. On May 1st, 1986, 16 months after the indictments and more than six months since the start of the trial, the jury filed into the courtroom to read the verdict.
在出庭受审的11名庇护工作者中，3人被宣判无罪。8人被判有罪，其中包括法伊夫牧师，这给律师巴茨·巴特勒带来了沉重的打击。陪审团宣判后，我是如此厌恶……我长期为之效力的这个体制……我不想再成为它的一部分。我们感到无比沮丧，因为我们的政府
Of the 11 sanctuary workers who went to trial, three were acquitted of all charges. Eight were found guilty, including Reverend Fife, which hit Bates Butler, the lawyer, really hard. After the jury came in, I was so disgusted... ...with the system... ...that I had worked in for so long. I didn't want to be a part of it. And we were so upset that our government
和我们的法院系统将带有道德立场当事人们抛弃了，我们觉得政府和法院已经破产，整个体制已经破产。但另一位辩护律师詹姆斯·布罗斯纳汉深知他们需要克服重大障碍。你知道，陪审团非常好，但他们带着自己的态度走进陪审团席。而这种态度就是，人们就是不能非法跨越边境。
and our court system had cast aside our clients with their moral positions, and that we felt like the government and the courts were bankrupt, the system was bankrupt. But the other defense lawyer, James Brosnahan, had known there were significant hurdles they needed to overcome. You know, juries are very good, but they come into the box with their own attitude. And the attitude is people just can't come over the border.
如果你打算这么做，你就得付出代价。移民归化局（INS）的露丝·安·迈尔斯认为裁决是公正的。参与庇护运动的人并没有将这些人引荐给移民局办公室。他们将这些人走私到美国。他们在教堂里给他们提供了所谓的庇护。他们没有遵守法律。接下来是法官的量刑。我们真的很担心法官会把他送进监狱。我的律师告诉我，宣判时在后裤兜里带上一把牙刷，因为他们对你恨之入骨。所以我已经和会众、家人以及所有事情做好了安排，做好了入狱的准备。
If you're going to do that, that, you gotta pay the price. Ruth Ann Myers of the INS thought the verdict was fair. The people that worked in the sanctuary movement did not present those people to immigration offices. They smuggled them into the US. They gave them, quote, sanctuary in their churches. They did not follow the law. Next came the sentencing by the judge. We really were worried that the judge was going to put him in prison. My attorney told me, take a toothbrush in your hip pocket when you go to sentencing, because they want you bad. So I had made arrangements with the congregation and with my family and everything, expecting to go to prison.
令我们大跌眼镜的是，他判处所有被定罪的人五年缓刑。考虑到他们在某些情况下被判犯有重罪，法官给出了相对宽大的判决。那一刻我们松了一口气。我想，我不知道他是怎么想的，但我觉得如果他给这些好心人判刑，公众舆论会对这感到糟糕。我想他可能意识到情况确实如此。许多庇护工作者，包括法伊夫牧师，回到了他们的社区，并继续
And much to our astonishment, he sentenced all of us who were convicted to five years probation. The judge gave them relatively lenient sentences, considering they'd been convicted of, in some cases, felonies. We were relieved at that point. I think, I don't know what he thought, but I thought that if he gave these nice people a jail term, it would be awful public opinion on that. And I think he had some sense that that might be true. Many of the sanctuary workers, including Reverend Fife, went back to their communities and continued
他们在庇护运动中的工作。教堂继续庇护人们。志愿者继续帮助人们跨越边境。许多庇护志愿者在审判的结案陈词中明确表示，他们不会停止这项工作。政府可能已经判处了约翰·法伊夫和其他七名庇护活动人士刑罚，但这几乎没有让他们的声音沉默，也没有阻止他们开展跨国十字军东征。
their work in the sanctuary movement. Churches continued sheltering people. Volunteers continued helping people across the border. Many of the sanctuary volunteers had made clear in their closing arguments in the trial that they wouldn't stop doing the work. The government may have sentenced John Fife and seven other sanctuary activists but it has hardly silenced them nor stopped them from a cross-country crusade.
在那时，政府就此收手了吗？我的意思是，他们一定知道你们在继续做他们刚刚起诉你们的事情？是的。他们在图森对我们收手了，但他们又进行了一次审判。在新墨西哥州，政府起诉了一名参与庇护运动的男子和一名女子，罪名是运送无证移民。该案的陪审团裁定他们无罪。就在那时，我们知道这场运动已经发展到陪审团不再判定庇护工作者有罪的地步了。就在刑事审判结束后不久，一群教堂和难民权利组织
And at that point did the government just back off? I mean they must have known that you were continuing to do exactly what they'd just tried you for? Right. They backed off us here in Tucson, but they tried one more trial. In New Mexico, the government charged a man and a woman who were part of the sanctuary movement for transporting undocumented immigrants. And the jury in that case found them not guilty. And at that point, we knew that the movement had grown to the point where juries would no longer convict sanctuary workers. Not long after the criminal trial had ended, a group of churches and refugee rights organizations
对政府提起了集体诉讼。他们指控的内容之一是，政府对危地马拉人和萨尔瓦多人提出的庇护申请进行了歧视性对待。1990年，政府与该诉讼达成和解。他们同意给予所有来自这些国家、没有证件的人临时保护身份和工作许可。并且他们同意对政治庇护程序进行一系列改革。因此，我们基本上开始逐步结束
filed a class action lawsuit against the government. They alleged, among other things, that the government had engaged in discriminatory treatment of asylum claims made by Guatemalans and Salvadorans. In 1990, the government settled the lawsuit. They agreed to give everyone who was here without documents from those countries temporary protected status, work permits. And they agreed to a whole series of reforms of the political asylum process. So we essentially began to wind down the
庇护运动。但尽管教堂放慢了工作脚步，庇护的理念却在传播。大学校园、城市、县，甚至整个州都开始宣布自己为庇护所。不仅为逃离迫害的难民提供庇护，也为更广泛的无证人员提供庇护。这一趋势在20世纪80年代加速，并延续至今。但庇护的准确含义因地而异。任何你想要的。
sanctuary movement. But even though the churches were slowing their work, the whole idea of sanctuary was spreading. College campuses, cities, counties, even whole states began to declare themselves sanctuaries. And not just for refugees fleeing persecution, but for undocumented people more broadly. This accelerated through the 1980s and has continued up to today. But what exactly sanctuary means varies from place to place. Anything you want.
这就是问题的一部分。而且每个城市可能都有点不同。再次有请律师詹姆斯·布罗斯纳汉。通常地方当局、警察、治安官不会协助驱逐无证人员。在某些地方，警察被禁止询问一个人的移民状态，或者将该信息提供给联邦政府。在其他地方，所有居民都被承诺可以使用城市服务，无论他们的
That's part of the problem. And each city is probably a little bit different. Once again, lawyer James Brosnahan. Usually the local authorities, police, sheriffs, will not assist in the deportation of undocumented people. In some places, police aren't allowed to inquire about a person's immigration status, or to give that information to the federal government. In other places, all residents are promised access to city services, regardless of their
移民状态如何。这些政策可以写入法律，也可以在实践中发生。唐纳德·特朗普总统在竞选期间经常谈论庇护城市，他将无证移民犯下的谋杀案作为庇护城市不应存在的证据。他威胁要扣减那些认定自己为庇护城市的联邦资金，他还承诺加速驱逐出境。作为回应，教堂再次开始庇护人们。
immigration status. These policies can be set in law, or they can just happen in practice. President Donald Trump talked a lot about sanctuary cities during his campaign, and he's pointed to murders committed by undocumented immigrants as evidence that sanctuary cities should not exist. He's threatened to pull federal funding from cities that identify as sanctuaries, and he's also promised to accelerate deportations. In response, churches are once again sheltering people.
我认为全国许多会众都在纠结，在现政府的领导下，忠于我们信仰的要求意味着什么。这是艾莉森·哈灵顿。她是图森南海长老会现任牧师，该教堂是20世纪80年代庇护运动的发源地。在奥巴马政府期间，她和她的会众为一对面临驱逐出境威胁的夫妇提供了庇护。他们现在正在讨论这项工作是否会在未来几年扩大。我的意思是，我无法忽视这样一个事实：我的前任约翰·法伊夫因为做我现在正在做的工作而被起诉，而且他面临着10年的监禁。我尽量不去想那个，但你无法忽视它。自2011年以来，教堂作为庇护所享有某种保护地位。在那一年，移民
I think a lot of congregations across the nation are struggling with what will it mean to be faithful to the mandates of our faith underneath this administration. This is Allison Harrington. She's the current pastor of Southside Presbyterian in Tucson, the church where the sanctuary movement began in the 1980s. She and her congregation provided sanctuary to a couple of people who were threatened with deportation during the Obama administration. They're now having conversations about whether that work will expand in the next few years. I mean, I can't ignore the fact that my predecessor, John Fife, was indicted for doing the work that I'm doing right now and that he was looking at 10 years in prison. I try not to think about that, but you can't ignore that. Since 2011, churches have had some protected status as sanctuaries. In that year, Immigration
与海关执法局在奥巴马总统领导下发布了一份备忘录。其中指出，一些敏感地点需要移民官员的特别考量。政府表示，除非是极端情况或获得更高层级的批准，否则我们不会进入这些敏感地点。这些敏感地点是礼拜场所、医院和学校。但这套做法并未编入法律，随时可能改变。最近有报道称，移民特工将医院和学校里的无证人员作为目标。
and Customs Enforcement under President Obama issued a memo. It said that some sensitive locations require special consideration by immigration officers. The government has said we won't enter into those sensitive locations unless it's an extreme situation or we have higher levels of approval. And those sensitive locations are houses of worship, hospitals, and schools. But that practice isn't codified into law and could easily change. Recently, there have been reports of immigration agents targeting undocumented people in hospitals and schools.
教堂也可能变得脆弱。这必须通过一系列机构决策以及法院决策在未来很长一段时间内得到解决。结果会是什么？我们拭目以待。没有人知道。这集分两部分的报道由德兰尼·霍尔于2017年制作。重播由马丁·冈萨雷斯制作并混音。原版技术制作由什里夫·尤素福负责。音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德提供。
Churches might also be vulnerable. That's gonna have to be worked out through a number of institutional decisions as well as court decisions well into the future. What's gonna be the result? We'll see. No one knows. This two-part story was produced by Delaney Hall in 2017. The rerun was produced and mixed by Martín González. Original tech production by Shreef Youssef. Music by Swan Real and George Langford.
感谢《心灵的信念》一书的作者米里亚姆·戴维森允许我们使用她对吉姆·科比特的采访录音。还要感谢亚利桑那大学特藏部的特伦特·帕迪和裘德·帕迪。凯茜·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、杰森·德莱昂、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉沙·马顿、约瑟夫·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、
Thank you to Miriam Davidson, author of Convictions of the Heart, for letting us use tape of her interview with Jim Corbett. And additional thanks to Trent Purdy at the University of Arizona Special Collections and Jude Pardee. Kathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney,
凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，还有我，罗曼·马斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于美丽的加利福尼亚奥克兰上城区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站上找到我们。我们正在蓝天（Blue Sky）上努力经营。你可以在那里以及我们自己的Discord服务器上加入我们。
Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites. We're making a real go of it on Blue Sky. You can join us there as well as our own Discord server.
我在Discord服务器上花了大量时间。在 99PI.org 上可以找到该 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 的所有过往单集。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I spend a lot of time on the Discord server. There's a link to that Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我在Discord服务器上花了很多时间。那里有一个指向该Discord服务器的链接，以及99PI往期节目的链接，网址是99PI.org。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。